- Before we get started,
we wanna let you know
that we got some tour
dates, we wanna invite you
to take it up and come see us for a night
of unpredictable comedy
and harmonious music.
How's that sound, Rhett?
- That sounded really good.
I might go to the show.
- We're gonna be singing
and talking to each other
and who knows what else is gonna happen
but sometimes it involves weird get-ups.
- Well every show's different.
We never know what's gonna happen.
- [Link] We're gonna be
in Las Vegas June 21st,
Salt Lake City June 22nd,
Denver, Colorado June 23rd,
Milwaukee, Wisconsin June 25th,
Indianapolis, Indiana June
26th, Detroit June 27th,
Omaha, that's in Nebraska June 29th,
Minneapolis, Minnesota June 30th.
- And then later in
the year we're gonna be
in Houston, Texas on September 4th,
New Orleans September 5th,
Birmingham on September 6th,
Jacksonville, Florida on September 7th,
Tampa, Florida September 8th,
Albuquerque, New Mexico November 20th,
Phoenix, Arizona November 21st,
Sacramento, California November 22nd,
and Valley Center,
California on November 23rd.
Again, these are all the
dates for the rest of 2019
and most likely for quite some time.
- So if you wanna see us,
now's the time to take it up.
RhettAndLinkLive.com.
Now on with the biscuit.
(upbeat electronic music)
Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting
we are exploring the question were the 20s
the best years of our lives?
- Now we didn't live during the 1920s.
It was like when we were in--
- The Roaring '20s?
- When we were in our 20s, was that the
♪ Best time of our lives ♪
- Have we peaked?
Did we peak long ago turns out.
- That's a different question.
Was it I think best and peaked are
two totally different questions and--
- Oh well sounds like you're
already answering the question.
- I have lots of thoughts on best.
And I think it has lots
of implications for how,
well I don't wanna spoil it.
- What about your best peaks?
- Are we gonna get back
into which kinda peak
you're talking about again?
(Rhett chuckles)
I do need to acknowledge that
my voice is otherworldly.
It's very, is it very DJ-esque?
- I feel like it's, yeah,
so Link's still a little
under the weather but I actually,
maybe I've adapted to your voice.
Maybe this is the new you.
I don't hear it anymore.
- I know it's like I'm still
having this head cold thing.
Is this permanent Link?
- Well you know what I've been--
- Is it my permalink?
- (chuckles) I've been in a constant state
of feeling like I'm getting what you have.
I've done things like I haven't
been going to work out--
- Of course.
- I canceled everything.
- You're in a constant
state of getting everything.
That's called being a hypochondriac.
- No, no, but I have physical symptoms.
I have slight headaches--
- That physical senses
manifest from--
- Slight sore throat--
- Hypochondriatism.
- Very slight
things happening.
But you know I think I'm gonna be okay.
- Well when we were riding in the car,
if I encounter anybody
I'm like don't touch me.
Don't touch me, it's for your own good.
And then we're in the car
and I'm like don't touch me
but I'm touching stuff in your car
and then I notice that
I finished my coffee
and I put the coffee down
and then you adjusted
the temperature gauge on your
car, whatever it's called,
your temperature dial.
You wanted it to be cooler, my friend.
And I couldn't help but
notice and I did point out
that as you were touching
the temperature dial,
your finger was rubbing
up against my coffee lid
where my mouth goes.
- Yeah 'cause you had this big, Thermos
you take everywhere.
Like why does it have to be so big?
Why do you need so much coffee?
- Why's it gotta be my Thermos's fault?
It's your fault for putting your finger--
- The Thermos is so big.
- On the--
- That it was blocking
the temperature controls.
- It's tall, man.
- There was no way
to adjust the temperature
without touching your mouth hole
on your Thermos.
- Everything's bigger with
the Linkster. (chuckles)
I'm like Texas.
I'm like Texas, man.
- I think you're just
compensating for something.
- Yeah I like to drink coffee, homey.
And listen, I was the gracious,
you never would have even
known that your finger
was touching my mouth
place on my coffee mug.
- Don't say mouth place, just
don't use that terminology.
- And then you, did you sanitize?
- I have since sanitized.
- I wonder what you touched on yourself
after you touched my mouth place.
- I'm actually,
I don't know if anybody's
got video evidence of this
but I feel like I've gotten
better at not touching my face.
- So you don't know if
people have video evidence
of you not doing something.
Like that's not how evidence works.
- No no you don't understand.
- I'm gonna present reams of video
and in none of this video
for the next two weeks--
- You're misunderstanding.
I think everyone's following along.
- You are not gonna see me touch myself.
- So if you have approximately a decade
and more specifically about
seven years of a daily show
of a person being themselves
in their natural environment,
that natural environment being a desk
that he shares with another man--
- That natural environment Rhett is a set.
How do you reconcile that?
- I'm there so much
that it's my natural environment.
- Okay it's not really a basement.
- And I'm saying my theory is,
listen, don't do this
'cause I don't want anybody
to do this but my theory
is that my frequency
of touching my own face
has decreased over time.
- Sure.
- Because I just feel like
I've become more conscious,
and I'll touch the hair.
- You'll touch the top of the head.
- This isn't the face, in fact--
- The face begins where the hair ends.
- They call this, I
heard somebody call this
the golden triangle or something.
- He's pointing at his mustache.
- I don't know if it's
your eyes, your mouth--
- And if you can't hear him,
he's calling it a golden triangle.
- Your eyes, your mouth and your nose
but it's basically an
ungodly high percentage
of the crap that will
make you sick goes in
through this place.
- Yeah.
- It's not like you get a
cut somewhere and get a cold.
I mean it does happen but it's going in
through the golden triangle.
I don't know if that's the term.
- What is the constellation that forms
this golden triangle?
Your two eyes and your mouth?
- It might be your two
nostrils and your mouth.
That's not really a triangle though,
that's more of a trapezoid.
But your eyes have holes.
Your eyes are holes.
Your eyes get stuff too.
Don't touch your face.
- Hey let's not forget eyes,
they get stuff too, guys.
- I believe that I touched my face less.
♪ I touch my face when
I think about germs ♪
- Have I touched my face yet?
How often do you touch your face?
- A lot, man.
I'm sick, dude.
- No no, you're not sick.
- Lily gave me this and I don't think
she was touching my face.
I don't know, sometimes
I'm doing that dad thing
where wouldn't it be funny if I acted like
I was poking you in the eye.
I probably poked my daughter
in the eye for the fun of it.
- That's not a dad thing.
No other dads do that.
Just speaking for--
- I'm a dad.
I'm speaking for one dad.
- All other dads,
hey I'm gonna poke you in the eye,
that's not a thing that dads do.
- Just like--
- What do you mean?
- Graze it.
I don't know, man, I
don't remember doing it.
I'm just saying it seems
weird for me to say,
oh I--
- I just touched my face.
- I touched my daughter's face.
- I just touched my face,
I'm very conscious of it.
- Yeah you did.
- I touched my beard.
Is that part of the triangle?
I think that's just
outside of the triangle.
- Below the triangle.
He went over the mouth.
- Can bacteria go up these
hairs and get into the mouth?
- What is happening?
Did we both just, are
we really caffeinated?
This is a different Ear Biscuit.
You never know what you're gonna get.
- Well we've had an interesting day.
We've traveled, we
traveled to the west side.
- It's been weird, yeah.
- It's always a little bit
exciting to see the other
side of Los Angeles.
- We ate brunch out.
Oh yeah so tell them about the lobby
and then tell them about the brunch.
- Yeah we had quite a day.
So this was the two of us and
Stevie going to a meeting.
We're always meeting with people.
- Tell them what the meeting's about.
- The meeting is about
making something awesome
into something even better. (chuckles)
- But different, on another meeting.
- It's about something
we really wanna happen,
we really want you to see--
- Because we wrote it
and we knew we want it
to be on television.
I mean I don't know why
we can't talk about this.
But let's not--
- I haven't thought about it
but you just talked about it.
I don't think there's any
reason not to talk about it.
- If we think about it
there might be reason
not to talk about it but
I think that's stupid.
You know what we're talking about.
- But in this particular place, see,
this is the reason that I didn't wanna say
what the meeting was about
because now I'm gonna give
characteristics of the lobby of the place
that we were and now people
are gonna know where it is.
- When you tell the people,
when you tell the listener
what it is we experienced,
then it will be clear to everyone involved
that the people who made
the decision for the thing
to be there wanted us to talk about it.
So we are exonerated.
- That's not exactly what I
was getting at but that's cool.
They have a koi pond in their lobby.
And for all, in every other way,
it's a pretty nondescript lobby.
There's not anything--
- It's not big.
- Sometimes you go into like,
I don't know if you've
ever been into the lobby
of CAA, the agency, the talent agency.
- It's not our agency.
- Not our agent but I
have been in the lobby.
- Not a sponsor.
- I do visit other lobbies.
I'm kind of a lobby connoisseur.
- Now if you visit other agents,
our agents are gonna start
shakin' in their boots.
- No no I just went to look at the lobby.
And also I'm also a foyer connoisseur.
Any sort of, the beginning
of going into a building,
whether it's a home or a
building, I'm really into.
- None of this makes
you a douche, go ahead.
- But this lobby was rather unimpressive
except for the fact that
they had a koi pond.
- Now I will say when you hear Rhett say
they have a koi pond, I
would venture to guess
that you picture like a
foliage-draped environment
with a dark water with some
sort of sediment at the bottom
like a pond and you would be wrong.
But I wouldn't blame you for it because
that's what I would picture.
Matter of fact even when
he said koi pond just then,
I still pictured it
even though I was there
and that's not what it was.
- It's pretty much just
sort of a rectangle
in the middle of the floor.
- It was like the tile
that made up the floor,
then if you went down a foot and a half
and then you laid more of that same tile.
It was very modern.
- But you think the koi
need more than that?
- I immediately felt sorry for the koi.
- Well what brings a koi joy?
Do you know?
Koi joy.
- Rhett you got me.
I don't know.
- I believe that koi joy
is found in just being coy.
- Let's come back to that.
So it's a square area with approximately
420 gallons of water.
- But of course things
like koi ponds in lobbies
usually aren't the kinda thing
that we cannot experience
and then not begin asking
questions to whoever's closest
which happened to be the woman
who was manning the desk.
- We had a good meeting.
- She was womanning the desk.
- We had good meetings.
After the meeting we're kinda flying high
and Stevie went to the bathroom
so we're just mulling around.
- I'm like hey--
- We're two old men
with their hands in their
pockets looking at koi.
- And I'm like hey receptionist.
I didn't call her that,
I just was like hey, you
responsible for these koi?
(chuckles)
And she said, "Well, yeah.
"If one of 'em jumps out."
You go what, if one of 'em jumps out?
- Okay don't get paranoid, lady.
- She was like, well, I
said, "Does that happen?"
She said, "Yes it happens
and they're very slippery,"
and then she picks up
the mail little tray.
The tray, the cage kind of
mail tray and she's like--
- Like a basket, like a wire basket.
- A mail basket.
- That you hold letters.
- She's like I just put
that on top of the koi
and I push the koi back into the koi pond.
So it's not a mail
tray, it's a koi pusher.
They got koi pushers.
- Koi catcher.
- It's a koi catcher.
- It's a koi catcher that brings me joy.
The weird thing she said was,
"Yeah, so sometimes big trucks
"will go by and then
they'll get kinda agitated
"and they'll jump out."
- Wouldn't you?
- What?
(chuckles) I don't know.
As if I didn't feel sorry
enough for these koi.
- But think about it, you're
just a koi, you don't know.
Think about, that's why
they're jumping out.
They wanna see what
the heck is driving by.
It's like--
- I don't think they want.
- You don't think they have wants?
- I don't think they have wants or joys.
- Why do you have so much of a clear idea
of what a koi needs?
Do you own one?
- Well we had friends who
house sat for a couple
that had a bunch of koi,
you know this, Rhett.
- Yeah and all the koi
died because somebody
did something stupid with the water.
- And who was sad?
- Well none of the koi
were 'cause they all died.
- Bingo.
How much, he had to pay like--
- 75 grand.
- $75,000.
- Koi are very expensive fish,
especially if they're old and rare.
- They can live like 111 years.
- Yeah something like that,
sometimes koi will be left
in someone's will.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause koi outlive the boys.
After the koi pond--
- Pushing a little too hard.
- The koi pond excursion.
- Trying to make a t-shirt.
- We had a little bit of time
before our next appointment.
Lots of appointments today
and so we got a little brunch
and we needed a quick bite but we wanted
to be a little bit fancy
and so for the first time--
- I'm on Yelp.
- First time ever,
we go to, well okay, I'm
not gonna say the name of it
because that's really what
makes this story funny.
So we decide on this place
that is a chain restaurant
that serves breakfast and coffee.
- Well it's like Panera but it's--
- A little fancier.
- You should spell it.
It's French.
- It's French.
In French it's the pickle
bread or something like that.
- Q-U-O, no,
L-E space--
- P-A--
- I-N--
- I-N, which is,
that's bread in French.
And then another word Q-U-O-T-E-D-I-E-N-E.
Q-U-O-T-I-D-I-E-N, I
was close enough, Jacob.
I just got two letters wrong.
(Rhett laughs)
- So there's a parking garage underneath
this particular establish
'cause there's multiple stores
or restaurants so we go
downstairs and the woman,
the parking attendant stops us, she says--
- You're driving.
- She says,
"Where are you going?"
And I froze because I don't
know how to say this place
and of course Link leans over and says,
"Le Pain Quentidon." (laughs loudly)
- Just like that.
- Le Pain Quentidon and I was
like what language was that?
- Well I was just so
enthusiastic because I was like,
ooh ooh I know the answer to this!
Le Pain Quentidon.
- No you did not say
it in a French accent.
You said it in some other accent.
- Le Pain Quentidon.
(Rhett laughs)
- (chuckles) And I wasn't being funny.
- But it was funny.
- I knew the answer.
And we needed to park.
- And I then said,
we all started to laugh, well
me and Stevie started laughing
and you laughed and the
parking attendant woman
sort of smiled and I said, "You know,
"they really need a new
name for that place,"
and she said, "LPQ."
- LPQ.
- And that's what
they call it there, they call
it LPQ so they don't have
to say Le Pain Quotidon.
(both laughing)
- Oh man, it feels good to say it.
- Yeah.
- It gives the koi joy.
(chuckles)
Le Pain Quentidon.
- So we have had quite a day.
- The menu was very promising
and the Yelp reviews were like,
there were over 700 Yelp
reviews of this place
and it had over four
stars like almost four
and a half stars.
- Well it wasn't bad it's just--
- And then it wasn't good.
- Well it wasn't bad.
The menu made me get
really excited and then,
I just didn't feel like it
completely delivered on the menu.
Also the coffee mug had no handle.
- I looked over--
- So I had to--
- This chick was over
there drinking her coffee
and she was holding it
like a treasured bowl
that you would--
- Serve the king.
- Oh yes,
the monarch needs to drink of this
or something the Pope
would use ceremoniously.
That's how she was
bringing it to her lips.
- And then you look over at me--
- And I was like why is she doing that?
- And I was doing the same thing.
- And you were doing the same thing.
- 'Cause you don't feel like you--
- I think that's what a quentidon is.
- You feel like you can
grab it with one hand.
- What is a quentidon?
- You said it was pickles.
- I know and you fell for it. (laughs)
Gotcha!
I got you, the whole day you been thinking
a quentidon is a pickle.
- Yeah I know but here's the thing.
- 'Cause it was on his plate.
- You, that's not the
kinda thing you joke about.
Just honestly, that's the
kinda thing I joke about.
- Just because you fell for it.
- (chuckles) No, you usually--
- Oh this is your type of joke.
- No no, you don't normally
do purposely deceptive humor.
That's the kinda thing
I tell my kids is like,
you know the quontidien
means pickles, and so,
you typically know French 'cause you--
- I typically do, yeah.
- It's funny,
we both took three years
of French but you retained
a significantly higher portion than me.
- Well (speaks in foreign language).
- French for the daily bread.
The daily bread.
Quotidien means day, daily.
- Okay.
- You shall not live by bread alone.
- It doesn't mean the
bread and pickles, sorry.
- And if you were to rewind
and re-experience this Ear Biscuit,
you would hear at the top,
Rhett gave a shout-out to pickles.
(tape rewinds)
- The pickle bread or something like that.
- 'Cause he was fallin' for my joke
and that really gave me koi joy.
That's why you do it.
- It's quite a long play.
- Exactly.
- Okay so I feel like I could
still recommend the restaurant
just personally, I would say
that I think you should try it
but I do think that you should say LPQ
just to not embarrass yourself.
Unless you're French.
- When you go to a French restaurant,
do you order by initials?
Give it a shot.
- No, CPK.
- California Pizza Kitchen?
- Yeah.
That's French, right?
- (chuckles) Yes.
- Okay we're gonna answer
your questions but first,
we're gonna let you know
that you can look just
as tie-dyed as us.
We just look like we
just took regular shirts
into a washing machine.
- Tie-dyed in the wool.
You got your hi daddies creepy creepy
Cotton Candy Randy.
- He's busting out of my chest.
- And you can call him and
he'll answer your question
and respond to your call
as part of the Mythical Society content
that's being cooked up and released
over the summer every Thursday.
- Yes he will.
- I got this Mythical tie-dye.
Describe it.
- That's a Randler with a third eye.
The all-seeing eye of
the Randler put into--
- You know what, don't describe it.
It takes away the mystique.
They can see it.
- See it with your third eye.
You know what, you can see
both shirts that we're wearing
with your third eye is the ironic thing.
But you can only buy
them at Mythical.store.
Can't buy things with your third eye.
- Would you rather have a
third eye or a third leg?
(sputters)
- Well if the third leg
is a euphemism for penis,
I already have one.
- Noted.
- So I think I'd go with eye.
- Okay, that was still
technically part of the ad.
(Rhett chuckles)
So that's Mythical.store.
That's what you get for
watching the video version.
- Right, you get extra stuff.
Let's start with a question from Annie.
Known as @CelestialLink.
I guess that's in reference
to you, Link, on Twitter.
- Yeah if I weren't me,
I would still devote my entire
Twitter experience to me.
- If you could go--
- And that would be
my choice as well.
- If you could go back in time
and bring one current invention with you,
which you would be credited for inventing,
what would you bring and why?
So you go back in time, you
can take something with you
and you will be credited
with inventing it.
- Is there a size limitation
on this time traveling device?
Let's say no.
- I would say no.
- I have a specific answer that then leads
to a more general and powerful answer.
You know what I'm gonna do it in reverse.
I have a general answer but
then I have a more specific.
Can I just, you wanna go first?
- No I'm interested, I do have an answer
but now I'm very intrigued.
- I would take back in time,
I would take an Aerobie.
You remember the Aerobie?
- I do, fondly.
- When we were in college,
we could not be satisfied
with a normal spinning, flying projectile
that you could throw and catch
in the little grass patch
beside your apartment.
No, we had to get the
world's longest flying device
that could be thrown from hand to hand.
We had to get the Aerobie.
- It's quite an amazing--
- A-E-R-O--
- Flying disk.
- B-I-E.
For those of you Googling this.
The flying ring.
- I think a boomerang version as well.
They made two different sizes,
maybe three different sizes.
- It actually comes back to you.
But they do not float.
They will fly a long way.
- They will sink in water.
- And they will sink in water
because we've lost a few
Aerobies in some ponds.
- And not just ponds, they fly so far,
sometimes they would
just go into the woods
and we would never ever find 'em again.
- Let me tell you,
some of the most exhilarating
experiences I think
we ever had were just getting
so far from each other
that we were questioning
whether we were still
looking at our friend.
- Yeah.
- And chucking this Aerobie
and then just seeing it soar
and then the thrill of
seeing that person catch it.
I gotta hand it to us, man, we were good
at throwing an Aerobie.
- We weren't great at
catching them though.
- Well it's not hard to catch it.
We were good at catching it.
If you don't catch it, it's pointless.
It's like a fail.
- It catches the wind
and sort of hovers and whoa!
- You'd think you were about to catch it
and you'd be right here with
your hands like splayed out
in front of your face
and then all of a sudden,
when it was like five feet
out and rapidly approaching,
it would catch a breeze like
a hawk going over a canyon.
Like catching--
- A thermal.
- A thermal, and it would
just, it would take off
and it would go another
400 yards it felt like.
- It felt like.
- It'd go another 38 yards.
I would take one of those back in time.
- And there's no place in Los
Angeles to throw one of these.
There's no open space large enough.
- The reason why this is top
of mine is because Lando,
we had some unstructured time
where we were hangin' out
a couple weekends ago and I was like,
whatever you wanna do bud, let's do it.
And his answer immediately was
I wanna go buy a tether ball.
That was his answer.
- Yeah.
This is a child that is used
to not having a lot of space.
- So he went--
- He needs a ball
tied to a pole.
- Right.
- That's its idea of fun.
- They play tether ball at school
and he fancied himself a semi-pro.
- Now you didn't buy him one did you?
- Hell yeah I bought him one.
- Okay.
- I ask him whatever
he wanted, I'll do it,
so I called the Big 5 and I was like
do you have tether balls
and they were like yeah.
- Of course they do.
That's pretty much what they're known for.
- Tether Balls R Us I think is
what they used to be called.
They were like yeah we got
those so we go over there,
I'm like whoa, they only have one left.
I was like this woman was risking a lot
in just that snap answer.
- Well it's probably been there for weeks.
- She should have said
we only got one left.
Better get over here right now.
I was like Lando, we're
just, snatch it, buddy.
- You're buying the one tether ball
people have bought in 2019.
Like okay now call the factory,
we gotta get another tether ball
because they're comin' in to get it.
- As we were leaving
with that tether ball,
I saw a guy walk in and I was like,
I looked at Lando, I was like,
he's gonna be disappointed.
I could tell he wanted a tether ball.
Before we checked out I went
past and they had an Aerobie
and I was like Lando, look at this
and I told him the story
that I just told you.
- Way better than a tether ball.
- And we also bought a $10 Aerobie.
- They don't have the big ones though.
- Yeah they do, yep.
- Okay you got a big one?
- Yeah.
- Where you gonna throw that?
- Well we went to the park and
they had a tether ball pole.
That's why he knew he
wanted to buy a tether ball
'cause--
- Oh you didn't buy the pole
and the base, you just bought
the ball and the string.
- Right.
- Find your own pole.
- A legit pole at the nearby playground.
- Bring your own ball and tether.
- There was no ball or tether
there, it was just a pole.
- Wow what is the world coming to?
- I know man, you can't leave
a tether ball hanging around.
Someone's gonna take that.
- Oh yeah.
Just like rims.
- Taking the rims
off a souped up Civic.
- Interesting that you
would take an Aerobie back.
So you think that would
gain you fame and fortune?
'Cause that was kinda
how I approached this.
- No.
Because I think it would be
cool and people would think
I was awesome but then as
I was making the rounds,
selling tickets for my exhibitions
of throwing the Aerobie and whatnot
and I would also educate the people
about the aerodynamic
design which would then lead
to the invention of the airplane wing.
Because I would go back that far in time.
- Oh.
- 'Cause you know,
even on the Aerobie
packaging it talks about
how it achieves lift like a wing
because of the way the lip
is designed, I believe.
So I would actually go back in time,
I was gonna just say I
was gonna take a wing
of a plane with me.
- Yeah but then the Wright
brothers would have invented
a giant Frisbee and we
still wouldn't be flying.
You'd probably screw the whole thing up.
It's like, no, Orville!
Trash the plans!
- I can tell by your--
- There's a man
with a flying disk.
- I can tell by your ridicule
that you are tracking
with my statement.
- So would you take it
to the Wright brothers?
- But I do disagree with it.
I would pre-live the Wright brothers.
I would be there in the late 1800s.
- Why don't you just skip the
Aerobie and go for a plane?
- I already answered that.
- Okay.
- The wow factor.
Two for one.
- I think the wow factor
of inventing aviation 'cause
who invented the Aerobie
in this universe.
- That's 'cause the plane
already existed.
- Do you know his name?
No, you don't.
- Well if the plane didn't exist then,
you would know his name and
that's why I'm going back
in time with an Aerobie to invent flight!
- I took a different tack.
I would, this is the
difficult thing to take back,
I admit that.
I would take Public
Storage back. (chuckles)
- What, oh.
You greedy.
I see where you're going with this.
- The guy who invented
Public Storage is a guy
named Brad Hughes.
He is worth $2.2 billion.
- Good gosh.
- In 1980--
- All he did was nothing.
- No, the story goes like this, my friend.
He needed to store some stuff
and he had a warehouse
and it was completely full
and he was like, what am I gonna do?
And he came up with the idea for what
he called private storage
which actually makes
a lot more sense.
- Yeah it does.
- But then when he took it to market,
he had changed it to Public Storage.
- For marketing reasons?
- He's like 85 years old.
The dude's worth over two billion dollars
because he just came up with the idea
that there should be little
cubby holes for adults
out in the world that
you can just pay for.
And no one thought of this until the '80s.
I mean, take that, Aerobie.
You know what I'm saying?
You just go back, I would
go back with, in fact,
my time machine would
probably be the storage bin.
And then I would just
unsheathe it and come out
and be like, this is
not only a time machine,
that's not really what's important.
Put your stuff in here.
Pay a monthly fee.
Hand me your money.
Now, here's the other thing.
'Cause I also was thinking
about the time period.
You gonna go back to the late 1800s?
- Okay okay okay.
- Before antibiotics?
I'm going back to 1980, brother.
You know what I'm saying?
- Tom Cruise movies.
- You basically have all the
luxuries of modern times.
There's less channels first of all.
I take all my storage money
and I just cruise around in a boat.
You could come your your
Aerobie and we could toss it,
I mean, my boat would be
so big that you could throw
a full-size Aerobie on it.
- But flight wouldn't exist
'cause I wouldn't have gone back in time.
- Okay.
So they're not mutually exclusive.
You could also--
- I think Public Storage
is like the one thing that the
majority of people on earth
when polled could agree
upon as being abhorrent.
Like there's just something about it.
- Yeah but here's the thing--
- That's like--
- You don't need to--
- You know what,
I'm having a negative response
to just you saying Public Storage.
- Okay how 'bout this?
Beanie Babies, that
guy's worth $1.9 billion.
- Oh is this your runner up?
- All you have to do is
take a Beanie Baby back
and you can take that back to 1986
'cause that's when he invented that.
- That guy's a chump, man.
- But it's a lot easier to
travel with a Beanie Baby--
- Stuffed animal--
- Through time.
- [Link] With beads in it.
- You know?
So maybe I just, you know what--
- At least that fits your
brand to talk about beans.
- I'd take a storage bin
full of Beanie Babies back.
And I'd be like I got
two ideas for you fools.
- Be like well I gotta
get a lot of Beanie Babies
before I can justify this
Public Storage thing.
- I think we've answered that.
- Sean-na Brown asks, is it
better to be knowledgeable
or better to be ignorant?
In other words, is ignorance truly bliss
or is it better to have
knowledge of something
even if it means it can
cause pain or chaos?
I'd say a corollary question
which we gleaned from Facebook.
From Megan Elizabeth Taylor, yes.
That Megan Elizabeth Taylor.
Would you rather be a worried
genius or a joyful simpleton?
Is ignorance truly bliss?
And how did you approach this question?
In your brain.
I don't know your answer of course.
- Well I took it, would
I rather be the kind of,
my state of being as a
person would be someone
who is knowledgeable about
everything including the things
that might potentially bring
me anxiety and trouble.
Or someone who is just unawares of things
that might bring worry.
And so as someone who is at
least somewhat knowledgeable
about enough things to bring
myself anxiety and trouble--
- Uh-huh.
- I would say that my knee-jerk
reaction is to say that I...
Me personally in the current state,
I wanna know things.
When we talked about the--
- The simulation, I mean,
all of that stuff, yeah.
You're always opting for knowledge.
- And we talked about the--
- Are you going the other way?
- No no, I'm saying me,
this version of me wants
to know things, including,
we talked about this on 23andMe.
Maybe we talked about this
but you can basically check,
yes I want to know if I've got--
- Predisposition to Parkinson's disease.
- Right, do I have the
specific genetic markers
to these illnesses?
- I actually don't know if
that's one specifically.
- I don't know what they are
but I checked all of those
and looked at all the information.
As soon as I had the opportunity to,
my instinct was just to look.
- Right but in the way
this is framed--
- But that's not how
I approach this.
- You're saying
if you could snap your fingers
and just be a different
person like different brain,
personality makeup, you would opt
to check your intelligence
at the door and walk in,
anticipating that what, you
would be a happier person.
- Well let me just say that I
don't think that I'm unhappy.
I don't think that I'm currently unhappy.
But if I had to choose between the way
that the second question
was phrased, worried genius
or joyful simpleton, like
if you're actually saying
the state of the genius
is that they're worried
or the state of the simpleton
is that they're joyful,
I would definitely
choose joyful simpleton.
And I wouldn't know what I was unaware of.
And so I'm--
- Yeah you wouldn't know
what you're doing though.
- I'm all about that, man.
I would definitely choose
that if I had the choice.
- I'm surprised by that.
I just feel like that's
really incongruent.
I still don't get it.
I just think...
I'm just trying to understand
what you're saying.
You're saying--
- I'm saying that me
right now, if there's
something to be known--
- If you'd rather be--
- In this version of me.
- It's basically would you rather be happy
instead of knowledgeable.
Burdened with some sort
of knowledge or freed
to just be happy.
- Yeah and I understand
that this seems inconsistent
with my answer about the
simulation and the matrix
but the way I was thinking
about that was is that
I actually knew that
there was a possibility
that there was something else
and I could experience it
by unplugging myself in the matrix
and then experiencing the real world.
- Yeah.
This you're so ignorant--
- This is like,
I'm literally--
- You do not know.
- My mind in this sense would not be able
to comprehend anything
that would bring me worry,
then I'm saying if the
alternative is being able
to comprehend those things
and then bringing grief,
that i would choose the joyful simpleton,
if you're giving me these two choices.
- And I thought that's
what I would choose too
but the way that I
immediately thought about it,
I'm like, what are
situations that I would opt
to not know about in order to,
'cause when people talk
about ignorance is bliss
they're usually talking about
a specific subset of knowledge
related to something,
but then I tried to come up
with what would be that thing
that's burdensome that I would be happier
if I didn't know about it.
But then I'm like well climate change.
Well no.
Obviously I would rather know about that
so that I could be engaged in
being part of the solution.
Even though it weighs heavily on the mind.
It's actually creeping up
constantly in the back of my mind.
I'm sure you would agree
that's a good thing.
We need more of that, more of that--
- Concern, yeah.
- Yeah just like
a discomfort associated with
the seething of our planet.
- But what if it was more personal?
- Okay so I have a personal example.
- Okay.
- If you have a relative who
they've got some indication
that something's wrong with them
and then they have tests
done and then they're waiting
on the tests to come back.
And especially being across the country,
it's not like you talk to
'em every day or you see 'em
and you know, where were you yesterday?
Oh I went into the doctor, it's like,
they kinda have to
volunteer this information.
And yes this has happened and I think,
maybe we've talked about this
but there's an inclination
to say I'm gonna spare you the knowledge
that I'm awaiting a test because
we think something's wrong
and it may be bad news.
I'm gonna wait until
I get the results back
and then I'm gonna give those to you.
Then I'm like well, yeah,
I understand that instinct.
I too have that instinct.
I don't wanna burden my mom
with something that's happening
when I don't really have answers
or there's nothing actionable.
Just as an example.
But I second-guess that,
as another example,
then I'm like I actually
don't think that works
because you're denying
their ability to love you
through the unknown and
that happens in life
and no one should go through the unknown
where they can only wring their own hands.
You wanna be able to hold hands
with somebody so to speak.
So that was my personal example,
that didn't work either.
So I'm actually unable
to come up with anything
that I would rather not
know when I approach it
from that way.
- Yeah but,
I guess what I'm saying is
is that you're approaching it
from this point in time--
- Sure.
- With these life circumstances.
So yeah now that--
- Can you think of one?
Can you think of a practical
example within that way
of approaching the problem that's like,
actually it's better not to know.
- No and I think we've talked
about this before, it's like,
my tendency is to believe
that knowledge about something
like data related to anything
is ultimately better.
- Knowledge is power.
- Than not having, than
not knowing something,
'cause you're gonna be
able to do something.
Even if it's knowing
when you're gonna die.
I don't know if we've specifically talked
about that situation.
But I think I would wanna know,
I think I would wanna know.
- Right but so skipping
back to the other way,
do you feel like you
know or have known people
who are more of the, they're
in more of an ignorant
and blissful zone?
I think I know people that way.
- Of course.
Well okay--
- Do you wish you
were one of those people 'cause I think
that brings it into focus.
- No because I'm not unhappy.
What I'm saying is this is
how I interpret the question.
Let's just say I'm in the
ether, my soul is in the ether
before I inhabit my next body.
- Okay.
- Not saying I believe
that this is how the world
works, but let's just say--
- You obviously do.
- That this is how
the world works.
- You wouldn't say it
if it wasn't true.
- And whoever makes
the decision about what
body you end up in says,
Rhett, I, of course they
voice of Morgan Freeman
which I can't do.
- That wasn't it.
- An impersonation of him.
But this is my voice so I'll use that.
He says, I'm gonna give you
a choice in this lifetime.
Would you like to be a worried genius
or a, what is it, joyful simpleton?
And I'm like those are my choices?
If I choose genius I'm gonna be a worried,
tortured genius?
You know, like Nietzsche.
Or--
- Le Pain Quentidon.
- Or you're going to
be a joyful simpleton,
meaning you're gonna be somebody
who know one knows about.
You're not gonna make any history,
you're not going to accomplish
anything that's great--
- Ooh.
- In the eyes of humans.
- I've seen Forrest Gump.
Ha!
- But no Forrest Gump was tortured.
He was knowledgeable enough
to be tortured about Jen-nay.
So I'm talking about
somebody who is just happy
but may need other people
to take care of them.
I don't know what they might need.
I would choose that scenario if presented
with those two options.
But if it was just like
would you rather be ignorant
or knowledgeable, I would
choose knowledgeable.
- Okay.
- Okay (sighs).
- I'm gonna choose to be
burdened and knowledgeable.
- Let's answer the
question that we started
this whole thing off with.
- Let's pay off that title.
- This is from Hanna--
- Unless it sucks
and then we change it.
- Hanna Brooks asks, your
20s are the best years
of your life.
In quotes as if someone told her this.
Do you agree with this?
What were the best years
of your life, and why?
- [Link] The 20s is, it's interesting
because I usually think
of it in terms of middle
school, high school, college,
out of college, married,
married with, that's
how I divide up my life.
Married, then married with children.
- Yeah.
- And then I can also
think about it in terms of our career
and I can start to put
different strata in there.
But like the 20s, that's the end of,
that's the tail end of college, right?
Yeah.
- The end of college, getting married,
and mostly everything that we did
before we really became
full-time YouTubers,
I mean, you know what I'm saying?
It was before we had
really found our calling.
- Boy.
- To what we kind of
have settled into now.
So it was a bit of a strange time.
- It was--
- Of figuring things out.
- Yeah and there was a lot
of, it was high stake peril.
It was like okay, what are we gonna do?
Why are we gonna, the heck is going on?
'Cause I feel like I'm
tempted to say the best days
of my life, I'd be tempted to
hone in on the college years
'cause those were some great years.
- Mm-hmm, yeah.
- You got this budding freedom.
You've got this blossoming self-discovery.
It's almost falling on
you like a dump truck.
Self-discovery is being dumped on,
you're just getting buried in it.
- Yeah.
- That's exhilarating.
You know, you hold your
breath and then you're trying
to breathe and get out from underneath it.
- And I think the reason
that adults will often say
to young folk, you don't
really enjoy this time.
These are the best years of your life
and they may be talking about high school
or college or whatever.
I think what they're actually saying is
if I with my knowledge and life experience
and wisdom that I have garnered
in the years that I've lived
were able to go back--
- Yeah.
- To high school,
or go back to college, oh
man I would just be able
to do it right this time.
But when you're in the midst of it,
you don't really understand,
and this is every stage of life.
- Okay so just to unpack
that a little bit, yeah,
'cause basically you're not
saying when I look back,
that was the best strata of my
life that I've experienced--
- I do think, well--
- It was youth is wasted
on the young is what you're saying.
You're saying that if I
could go back and re-do it,
I could most definitely make
it the best time of my life,
that decade.
- Well and listen I'm not saying
that I didn't take advantage of it
and that I didn't take
advantage of that freedom.
I specifically remember
that first week of college
of just comin' back to my
dorm room whenever I wanted to
and thinking this is awesome.
Having responsibility for
just myself is really awesome.
Now at the same time, I was really,
not as much as you now
that, I didn't even know
at the time 'cause you
didn't really talk about it.
I was really concerned about my academics.
Especially in freshman, sophomore year,
I was like super committed to studying
and making good grades and I
do recommend making good grades
but I think I placed a
little too much importance
on that, honestly.
I kinda got into a
little bit better groove
in my junior and senior year but...
I do think they were the best
years of my life in one sense.
- Oh you're not talking about 20s though,
you're talking about college.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Considering the nature of the discovery,
the nature of the fact that--
- I do think it's a candidate.
- Sit out and have these
philosophical conversations
that you had never
really had in high school
and really meaningful
friendships that went beyond
sort of the typical
high school friendship.
True friends and independent living
and independent experience
with being able to go off
and say we're gonna take
a trip to somewhere.
We're gonna go camping together
us four guys or whatever.
Those were things that
there were so many firsts
without any parental
supervision that it was awesome.
- And not just...
Our lives were different
because right out of college,
we got married but when
we were talking to Stevie
on the way to that meeting, she was like,
what was the show she asked us if we saw?
It was like...
Dead?
- Dead to Me?
- She was like have you seen Dead to Me?
No I never even heard of it.
She's like well it's a good concept.
I don't how well it was
executed but it's binge-worthy.
And I'm thinking,
I'm not in my 20s, I don't
sit around and just look
for stuff that's borderline binge-worthy.
I've got, I didn't jump
down Stevie's throat,
this was all in my brain but I'm like
I've got children and I've got
all the stuff that I'm doing--
- There is no bingeing.
- Within my own parameters.
- The only bingeing--
- I got a bed time!
- The only bingeing
that has taken place
for me is those two days
that I was on my back after the vasectomy.
- Right.
- And you can really only get
a vasectomy once.
I might get my vasectomy reversed
just so I can get it again
just so I can binge-watch television.
(Link chuckles)
That's literally the only
binge-watching I've done in 15 years.
- Stevie's still in her 20s isn't she?
- No she's 31, man.
- (chuckles) Whoops.
Not in my mind.
Sorry Stevie.
(Rhett laughs)
I just mean everybody here
is in their 20s in my mind.
- Okay, thanks for clarifying.
- Whoops.
(Rhett laughs)
But you know what I'm saying.
- So what's your point?
- My point is, what is my point?
My point is the 20s are the
time for a lot of people
where it's like, they
just got time to do stuff
but for us, the 20s were oh,
we've thrust ourselves into marriage.
- And thrust is probably
not the better word.
- We thrust, we've been
catapulted out of college
and out from under any
sort of financial support
that our families or whatever offer,
and now we're trying to make this happen.
This was like a scrappy time.
It was nerve-racking.
- Mm-hmm.
- I was talking about, we
both had our engineering jobs
and we were hatin' 'em
and I wasn't realize
I was hating them until you
kept insisting on how much
I should be hating it,
then I was like yeah man,
you're right, let's
figure out something else.
Let's get together one night a
week and come up with comedy.
- Yeah comedy nights.
- You know,
come up with comedy.
Then get up the next morning
and get to the spreadsheets.
And Christy was teaching,
she had a math degree
and she taught high school math.
She taught geometry and junk like that.
And she was going crazy,
going nuts just trying
to figure out how to teach high schoolers
and she was only four
and a half years older
than some of her students.
- Mm-hmm.
- She laid down the law the first day,
she was sending people out right and left.
It was carnage.
- Paddling them?
- (sputters) Yeah.
- She was a paddler.
- Spank me, Miss Neal.
That doesn't work.
She didn't fall for that one.
But so we're both putting
our heads together
and trying to figure out how we survive.
- Right but I mean--
- I'm house-sitting
for this couple who was out of the country
and we're taking care of
a full-grown Weimaraner.
- Yeah but you look back on
those times with nostalgia.
- No I don't.
- I do.
- I do, well--
- Any time that there's--
- That period was difficult.
- That scrappy period.
- First year of marriage.
I wouldn't wish that on my worst enemy.
- Well let me just tell you the way that--
- And Christy would say the
same thing, you skip that.
- Well you can't, I
process this in this way.
Okay, I'm 41 and...
Especially related to personal health,
physical and emotional
health are things that
it isn't that I haven't
cared about those things
but I have in the past decade or so,
especially probably the past half decade,
just getting older has sort
of forced me to be like,
I've gotta get on top of
this and I'll use my back
as an example of something
that has sort of applied
to a lot of different areas of my life.
- Talk about your back problems.
- So (chuckles),
I never did anything about my back
when I was in high school,
when I was in college.
Never did anything in my 20s.
Didn't really do anything
about them in my early 30s
but when it became like okay
this is gonna be a problem,
if I don't do something about this,
I'm going to have, I'll be
in a wheelchair someday.
I will have life-long, I will be disabled.
I'm not kidding, my back
problems were that bad
that if I didn't do something about them,
I was going to be disabled.
And I started to do the
things that I started to do
and continue to do and now
it's like my back is healthier
than it was when I was in high school
in terms of the way that it feels
and how often I have pain, right?
And it's a daily struggle
to continue to do the things
that I need to do.
But what I think a lot
of times, I'm like man,
when I was 22 years old, I
had a 22 year old's spine.
You know what I'm saying?
Like now I've got probably
like a 60 year old spine
because I didn't do anything all that time
and so the way I kinda process it is yes,
those were good times
but I've actually had,
and again, the back is just
an example of other things
like again, I started going
to therapy last year so I,
it wasn't like there was some necessarily
some acute problem, there were some things
that kinda came up that
led me to finally say,
okay yeah, I do need to go to therapy.
But there was a lot of
years where I just--
- You don't think going
blind was an acute problem?
- Yeah I'm saying that was
one of the things that--
- Okay.
- Wasn't going blind, you
can listen to that podcast,
but there was an acute problem
that kinda sent me over the edge.
All that to say though
is that I feel like now,
the thing that I can't line
up is caring about yourself
and taking actual steps
to care for yourself
and set that on top of youth.
That would be an
incredible thing and maybe,
maybe that doesn't happen
because when you're young,
you just don't feel a need
to address these things
in the same way.
You're like I've got all my life.
- Youth is wasted on
the young but to answer
the question, are you saying that the 20s,
or maybe you're saying
college, either one,
was the best decade of your life?
I'm not talking retro-fitted,
I'm talking about just for what it was.
- I think and maybe this
is just the futuristic,
optimistic part of me,
I still always have a
sense that I am entering
into the best years of my life.
You know what I'm saying, I'm saying--
- That's weird.
- It didn't get much better.
- That seems weird to me in a good way.
- It doesn't get that much
better than what I experienced
in my 20s and in college
and all those cool memories
or whatever, but there
were things about me,
the way I thought, the
way I approached life
in relationships, et cetera, that I'm glad
I don't still think and do the things
that I did at the time.
I like the me that I am now more
than the me that I was then.
And I would hope that that is
a progression that continues.
I hope when I'm 50, I look
back at 41 year old Rhett
and I like the me now more
than I like the me then.
What else is life about, right?
Now there's this sort of sinking feeling
that eventually age will become
an insurmountable problem
and that no matter what you do,
you're gonna die of something,
you're gonna have
chronic pain or whatever,
maybe there's nothing
they can do about my back
20 years from now, who knows.
Not looking forward to that
and answering those questions
but I'm just saying that
and I told this to Jessie,
I was like I think my 40s
are gonna be the best years
of my life and then I think
when I enter into my 50s,
I'm hoping that my perspective will be
I think my 50s are gonna be
the best years of my life.
- Yeah I--
- That's my attitude.
- I've already ruled out
the 20s and I told you why.
- Okay.
- So I think for me,
I think the nows, 'cause I'm 40.
I don't think it was the 30s.
I think I agree, I feel like we're on the,
I'm in year one, you're in year two
of the best decade.
I think the 50s won't be as good.
(Rhett laughs)
Hey, what about grandkids?
- Why man?
- I don't think that's gonna help enough.
I think--
- Our kids are gonna be like
50 before they have children.
That's up to them.
- I am the best,
I feel like I'm the best version of myself
that I've ever been and I want
to be an even better version
of myself and I think I'm on that journey,
semi-aggressively and I
think that's a big part of...
Well, that's a big part of
what makes me satisfied is that
I feel like I'm growing
and knowing more about myself.
Discovering more of
myself and who I can be,
self-realization I guess you'd call that.
- And I actually think that there's,
and I think we grew up with
this, sorry to interrupt
but to add to what you're saying.
I think that we kind of had this,
and I feel like there's a little bit
of an American ideal here
to be like stay the same.
He's the guy that he was when he was,
I'm still the same man that I
was when I was 20 years old.
I'm still the same, you know
what I'm saying, I'm like--
- Don't confuse it with a southern accent.
(both chuckle)
- I'm saying that I'm from the south.
In many different ways that
mentality was around me.
- Okay.
- And so that's how
I'm characterizing it.
- All right that's fine.
- I'm not making a
judgment about the south,
I'm making a judgment about who
I was and where I come from.
And what I'm saying is that I
believe that constant growth
and constant change is
actually a sign of health.
Not stagnation.
- Well I mean,
if it's the right kind
of change of course.
- Yeah of course.
- Of course.
- A change in the right direction
but I'm like what is life
if it isn't change in the right direction?
If you're not evolving
in a certain direction--
- You're only dying 'cause you are dying.
You might as well be growing
and living at the same time.
- And the idea of settling
into a way of thinking
and a way of doing,
as soon as I reach my
adulthood and then just being
that way forever, now
maybe you were enlightened
at age 21 and you just stayed the same.
I'm not anywhere near enlightened
but I'm just trying to
move in that direction
and so to me that's what
life has become for me
is being like oh, this is what it's about.
It's about right here,
it's about this moment,
it's about moving in the right direction.
- Yeah, let me put it this way.
There's the phrase live your best life
and I'm saying that to people constantly.
Stranger in the malls.
- You and Joel Osteen?
- Live your best life.
Did he come up with that?
- I think he has a book
called Live Your Best Life Now.
- Oh well he added now.
Well crap, I'm freakin'
deriving a Joel Osteen novel,
not novel.
- Is it Olsteen or Osteen?
- Who cares?
I don't care.
Osteen.
- Osteen.
Well you're talking about Olsteen.
- Ironically--
- You're not talking
about Olsteen.
- I didn't realize that
his book was exactly
what I'm saying which is
life your best life is something
that you're constantly doing now. (laughs)
I totally agree with this guy.
- And this is when Joel Osteen
walks in.
Fellas, I'm so glad--
- That you finally
figured it out.
- You finally figured it out.
Come to my big ol' church. (chuckles)
We've got 700,000 people every Sunday.
- It's making a decision to say,
you tend to focus on the
future and you put it in terms
of in the future I want
the future to be my best,
but I want this week or maybe,
I think it's unfair to say this day.
Depending on what you're going through,
it might be this week or this month.
- Just say now like Joel.
- But I think having a mentality of...
If I know that I don't
have plans this weekend
and I can either say I'm gonna do nothing.
I'm gonna let it come to me.
I feel like for me personally,
more often than not, that's a mistake
because it sets me up for
not living my best life--
- Now.
(Link chuckles)
- But instead just kinda waiting for it,
it's like livin' for the weekend,
it's like what about Wednesday?
What's my best Wednesday?
- Now.
- Or if I am on the
precipice of the weekend
or if I'm thinking about it,
it's like what's something
that I can do that sets up
as we've talked about before
in the context of the kids,
what are some things that
we could set up loosely,
not gripped too tightly
like the song goes,
that will create the
opportunity for an experience
that could be the best of that.
The best experience I could have this day
and that may be sitting on the couch
and binge-watching whatever Dead to Me is
that I'm never gonna watch, by the way.
- It's dead to you.
- But you know what I'm getting at?
It's like I do feel like--
- You talkin' about living
your best life now? (chuckles)
- If you have a mentality of all right,
I've got this.
I'm gonna find some enjoyment
or some fill in the blank
that brings some bestness to it.
- Yeah you talkin' about
gratitude and mindfulness.
Yeah and that is a challenge for me
because I am so future-oriented
and so I was--
- And a lot of people
are past-oriented, they're like man,
those were the good ol' days.
- Yeah.
- And I look back, I think you looked back
and I do the same thing and that's like,
well if I would have
known that I had the back
of a 20 year old, I would
have done things differently.
And again, that's a revisionist thing--
- And I can't do anything about it.
- Can't do anything about it.
- I don't have,
if I sounded this way, I didn't mean to.
I don't have regrets about it necessarily,
I'm just happy that my wife made me go
to a certain physical therapist
who finally gave me the right information.
One thing led to another
and I'm doing things
that are helping my back
live its best life now.
- Are we just doing pop
psychology, like vapid,
empty pop psychology here?
Or is it just that simple?
- I honestly don't care if we are.
If we are, who cares.
Is it effective?
Does it make it--
- All we need is love.
- Does it make a difference?
- Just throw that in there.
- Because we're pretty
complex creatures, us humans,
and our brains and, we've
got like we've said before
many times and somebody
else said it before me,
we've got Stone Age hardware
and we're running
modern-day software on it
and it leads to a lot
of different problems.
And I think that you can live a life
where you're constantly stressed out
and there's a bunch of cortisol
in your blood at all times.
- Yeah.
- Or you can find
some simple coping
mechanisms that help you
get out of your own head
and get out of your own way,
separate yourself from your thoughts
and realize that you are not your thoughts
and find some joy in
the moment and also look
to the future with optimism.
And I'm not saying that we have done this
or are experts at it by any means.
I think just what I'm saying is that
we spent a lot of time,
we're so focused on accomplishing
things and succeeding
at things that I think a good
portion of the last couple
of decades of our lives have
just been completely consumed
with trying to succeed.
We've had no time to stop
and think about things
like personal health
and growth in many ways
because we've been so
focused on our career
and just trying to keep up with things
and trying to be good
dads and good husbands
and the things, and the responsibilities
that we feel like the world has put on us
but I feel like sort of the one addition
that has happened to me
in the past few years
in therapy has been the most
tangible catalyst for this
is just this sense of working on myself
and it has made me, the
thing I told Jessie,
it was like, I feel
just a lot more excited
about the next chapter of my life.
If I'm dividing my life into two halves,
and I'm kinda entering
into the second half,
I am approaching it with
a lot more excitement
and not just sense of regret
about what I didn't do
but more about what I'm gonna get to do
and of course, it can all fall apart
and I could face incredible disappointment
and tragedy and whatever it might be
but what I'm trying to
do is get to a place
where the external
circumstances and the outcomes
don't affect my well-being as much.
- I think a factor for
me in being in this point
is the fact that we've
experienced the success we have.
I feel like in my brain and my heart,
it's given me the space
to then explore things
that I didn't give myself permission to do
and I'm not proud of that.
I think that's a lesson learned
that I don't like turning this
into something prescriptive.
I just like sharing our own experience,
so I'll keep this on myself
and say to my past self,
in terms of more self-discovery
and allowing myself that time for myself,
even though I was chasing after things
and the reason why the 20s
were such a perilous time
was because we were scrappily
trying to make things happen
and it was...
There's an art to living
your best life now
in the midst of those things, right?
We just happen to be at a point where,
I mean everything's not going great.
It's not but there's an art to that,
whatever life throws at
you, there's still a...
There's still space for
there to be some bestness
and you deserve to have some bestness.
- Yeah.
- So I'll leave it at
that, but I think it's,
I'm gonna say not the 20s, the 40s.
- The 40s.
- The 40s and beyond
are the best years of our lives.
And with that--
♪ Those were the best years of our lives ♪
- I'm gonna leave you with a rec.
♪ Rec baby rec baby ♪
♪ One two three four ♪
♪ One two ♪
- It's a book that's made a
big difference in my life.
- A book.
- Joel Osteen's--
(Link chuckles)
Live Your Best Life Now.
- What a coincidence.
- Yeah I planned on recommending this.
No, I can't say that I
would recommend that book.
I don't know Joel, haven't read the book.
Good for you if you've read it
and you got something
out of it but what I,
I actually was planning on
recommending something else
but I am gonna recommend
something I recommended before
but I'm gonna say it again.
Therapy.
- Did you just change your answer?
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- I actually had something
else but I can save it
'cause it was completely unrelated and
I can use it for another time.
I've talked about it before
but I know that I thought
that there was a stigma
attached to therapy
'cause I thought that you had
to have an acute mental issue
in order to go to therapy but to me,
if you wanna use the analogy of a car,
I think that the idea of I
don't take my car in, man,
until I got a problem. (chuckles)
You know what I'm saying, man?
But I think if you want your
car to continue to run clean,
you want it to be trouble free,
you take it in for the
scheduled maintenance, man.
And the scheduled maintenance--
- You can watch my daughter on The View
or whatever she's on.
- In the scheduled
maintenance of your body,
there's an interesting dichotomy
that somehow in our culture
we have this huge mind-body split
and like yeah, I got a
problem with my knee.
That's something I can
talk to my boys about.
I know that I'm characterizing
everyone who's ignorant
as with a southern accent
and I'm just doing it
because that's where I'm from--
- I just think that was
George Bush specifically.
- Those are the kinds
of accents that I do.
But trust me I'm a redneck at heart,
so I've got nothing against that.
But the idea that you can talk freely
about your physical
problems but when you get
to talking about mental
problems that suddenly,
this isn't something you
can share with a friend.
This is something that
you're gonna be judged for,
that's an unfortunate
side effect of something
that's gone wrong with
this particular society.
- When you say mental
you mean emotionally.
- Mental and emotional.
- All types of--
- And I think that I wish
I had discovered it earlier
and I highly recommend it and
I know that for a lot of
people, cost is an issue
and I don't know what
the solution is for that.
I know at one point we
recommended Better Help
but then you couldn't
recommend Better Help
because there was some
controversy around the people
that I don't know even what the deal was
but they're not a sponsor anymore.
But I don't know what the alternatives are
for sort of low-cost
mental health help, but
I'll just say that--
- I think they have clarified their,
the qualifications of the people
and that cleared some things up
and they also refined what types of issues
that they're tackling.
- Okay so do your own research in that--
- I'm not gonna say that it
is a legitimate recourse.
I would encourage people to
check that out on their own.
- Yeah so I'm just saying
that do your own research
to find out where affordable,
you can get some affordable
therapy but I would just say
that I believe that it's a priority
and there's probably some things
that you're spending money
on that may not be as important and so,
do what you can to find that help.
- All right.
- It's important.
- It wasn't a book, it wasn't an album
but that was pretty good.
- Yeah, pretty good.
- All right #EarBiscuits,
keep talkin' at us.
And we always enjoy hearing your feedback
and also, we enjoy hearing
if you introduce other people
to these conversations.
Hey you should check out Ear Biscuits.
These guys are fill in the
blank with whatever you think
will resonate with them.
Make it up if--
- Lie to them if you need to.
- Just fabricate--
- All marketing--
- The entire thing.
- All marketing is lying,
so just lean into it.
- Yeah, yeah.
Just, we need it.
- If you think--
- Oh we're in your ears.
- If you think your friend
would be more into two women,
just say it's two women
and they're really funny.
- But whatever.
- It'll take a few episodes
for them to figure it out but hopefully
they'll be hooked by then.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)